well cops like me
because they can talk to me more than
they can talk to their own wives some of
them did the cops like you
like i said a friendly nuisance i got in
the way
they watch all the cop shows on tv do
you know uh
joseph wamball police story you ever
watched that huge fan oh
i got a lot of my insights right there
really joseph wambach police story
got some tremendous insights into not
just the gimmicks the actual things the
tidbits that you would pick up from
their procedures
but the mechanics behind that the logic
behind it
was i would not allow myself to walk
into even a potential trap
i would not allow myself to walk into a
trap because i knew exactly how their
minds work from watching womba
what kind of trap are you talking about
and one of those was
talking about those crimes too much to
people
initiating conversations about that the
classic is talking too much about the
crimes
over interest you have to remain casual
it would be a guess but i'd say
right now far more than 35.
in north america more than 35. 35.
well i'm not an expert well holden i'm
not an expert i'm not
an authority i'm someone who has been a
murderer for almost 20 years
i'm just an extremely accomplished
murderer i was also involved in killing
co-eds because my mother was associated
with college work
college co-eds she had a very violently
outspoken position
on men and had had a very strong and
violently
outspoken position on men
then comes this picture postcard groovy
happy young couple on the stairs they
walk right past
walking up to my apartment past a happy
young couple coming down the stairs
who nodded and smiled at me as they went
by
good evening your two worlds are
colliding my murderous fantasy life
and this that's a pretty girl pretty
name
kim or something going out on a date
where i'd love to be going
and i'm aware of both of these realities
and then this the distance between those
two is so
dramatic so amazing so violent
and this craving this awful raging
eating feeling inside
i could feel it consuming my insides
i could feel it consuming my insides
fantastic
passion
uh it was overwhelming me i wasn't
impotent
but emotionally i was impotent
physically
i wasn't impotent but emotionally i was
i knew a week before she died i was
going to kill her i knew a week before
she died i was going to kill her
she went out to a party she got close
she came home alone i was woken up by
that
i got came out you know that night i
walked up to her bed and
she's like playing reading paperback
as many thousands of nights before
she says oh i suppose you're going to
want to wait up
all night and talk now can you believe
that
i looked at her i said no i said good
night
and i knew i was gonna kill her you know
and i knew i was gonna kill her you know
i was honest with myself for the first
time
that's the first time in 10 years i've
looked at it that way
i mean that intensely that honestly
it hurts a six young woman dead
because of the way she raises her son
and the way her son is raised
the way he grows up and now everyone
knows it was because of what she did to
me
because the way she treated her son i uh
rationalized that to give up would be
insane to give up would be crazy
i'd be giving away my freedom and i
don't need to
but i look back on that and wish i had
earlier
when i was saying those things to myself
the people who were later dead
wouldn't be the regret that came later
would have not had to be
those people not things those people
would still be with their families with
their loved ones
i know it's silly but mom always likes
people to look up to her
whoa